in honor of women's history month today  the mob museum put on it's a woman's  world crime scene investigation in las  vegas it's a panel of metro's female  leaders and they discuss the impact  women have in the field of crime scene  investigation a hot topic at the event  career paths for prospective csi  professionals  i think this is a great field for women  who are wanting to  provide  service to their community in  the broader field of law enforcement but  maybe don't want to  be a police officer so this is a really  good avenue for them to apply science  backgrounds  you know biology and chemistry to be  able to help our community  in different ways that  you know most people really only just  see on tv  the panel also talked about the  evolution of forensic science and  challenges facing forensic evidence in  criminal courts